children will usually find a way to play
but these kids are in the AL for camp in
Jordan their smiles hi tragedy they fled
the horrors of their homeland Syria the
United Nations say they are just a few
of the 30 million children who have been
forced from their homes displaced adults
number another 30 million the war in
Syria has sent a new wave of people
seeking safe haven even though all many
want to do is to go home this lady fled
her home Enid lip the money I hope God
makes it easy for us to go home she says
and we're not comfortable here random of
durban the UN High Commissioner for
Refugees Antonio Gutierrez says
politicians have to put helping people
above pleasing their voters since the
beginnings of civilization we have
treated refugees as deserving of our
protection whatever our differences we
have recognized the fundamental human
obligation to shelter those fleeing from
war and persecution yet today some of
the wealthiest among girls are
challenging these ancient principle
casting refugees as gatecrashers job
seekers or terrorists Hollywood star and
refugee activist angelina jolie is in
Turkey to visit Syrian refugees she's
appealing for sympathy for those who
have lost everything